I've always believed that technology is
the kind of handmaiden or the engine of
a lot of freedom once you once you have
better technology people can live more
on their own or we have more developed
markets so like I don't have to churn my
own butter and make my own clothes Etc
and a lot of that is it's both policy
and political Theory but it's also just
technology I think that what we have
seen over the past couple of hundred
years at least is that the technology
that allows us to live more freely
outpaces the the growth of the
government to kind of hem it all in and
I think that's part of my optimism I
mean government is growing but there is
a surplus of
autonomy that comes from these things